Here’s an example.
If your client code is making use of the GUI toolkit component that allows the n
users to type into a text box the client code can register the name of
a callback operation that should be invoked when the end user types into a,
types into the field.
During the period of this call the client callback operation has access not only
to the event itself, but the other elements of the component state,
such as the type text, the specific text box, and
even the pixel position of the cursor on the screen.
The client can take advantage of this information to do things like
suggest completions or fix spelling mistakes.
Imagine further that while com-,
computing possible work completions, the client makes a direct call to
the GUI component asking it to display a message.
When the callback code eventually returns control the component there is
no guarantee that the state of the text box is the same as it was before.
It might not even be visible anymore.